Austin asks when someone gives you a
horrible glass of wine how do you
politely get rid of it Austin when
somebody gives me a horrible glass of
wine I have no version that is polite in
response to such a negative action I'm
just kidding uh you know I don't know my
mom crushed it I mean we've talked a lot
about her like it's very easy it comes
very natural for me to be polite i I'm I
really took a lot of pride in being the
anti snob in the wine world and for me
to be like this is crap you know I'm
always using the hedge terminology of
like oh thanks you know by the way if
you like this you should really try this
and that's kind of my polite way of
saying like this is crap you should
check this out you're going to like it a
hell of a lot more and and by the way it
doesn't offend me and I also you know
listen there's a big part of me that
loves tasting crap wine because it gives
me context it's one of the reason I like
following so many of you on social media
so many of you are putting out such crap
content it reminds me what is good
content and I know that sounds harsh and
I know a lot of your like woo right and
I know it's a rule to not diss your
audience I'm coming to you with straight
love this is another ramp that I'm going
to do this once every twenty episodes
you're watching this you're engaging
your all giving me these dabs you're
leaving comments in YouTube you're
giving me big ups and then I'm watching
and I've had a little bit of vacation
time where I work a little bit I've had
a little bit of travel time where I've
look a little bit more I'm getting very
deeply inspired slashed connected to
let's say the core 1000 of you that
watch this show and I've been going down
the rabbit hole and i just want to
remind all of you lack of consistency is
a is a massive vulnerability oh crap
wait subscribe do I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe